represento a un gran país
a mexico
que tiene
una historia
y una tradición cultural
como la de otros pueblos
del mundo
podría aquí hablarles de
las grandes civilizaciones
fueron parte
de la fundación de lo que ahora es
nuestro país
de las grandes culturas que florecieron
en lo que hoy es méxico
hablo de civilización hablo de culturas
por qué
los que conquistan los que dominan los
que
y colonizan
siempre tratan de justificar sus
atrocidades
descalificando a los pueblos originarios
llamándoles
bar bar sus salvajes
no es el caso
y méxico
de nuestro pueblo como tampoco de otros
pueblos del mundo dominados conquistados
colonizados
nosotros
tenemos una extraordinaria historia
también de lucha
por la libertad por la justicia
por la igualdad por la defensa
de nuestra soberanía nacional
ay
tres grandes transformaciones en la
historia de méxico
primero
la independencia cuando después de
300 años
es el color nieve
obtuvimos
nuestra independencia
esa fue la primera transformación
a principios del siglo 19
2 curas rebeldes miguel hidalgo y
costilla
y josé maría morelos y pavón encabezaron
en movimiento
que se logrará la independencia de
méxico y también un movimiento en favor
de la justicia porque fueron los
primeros en proclamar la abolición de la
esclavitud luego tuvimos una segunda
transformación a mitad del siglo 19 muy
importante y de trascendencia mundial
el movimiento de reforma que encabezó
un gran dirigente un liberal
el mejor presidente que ha habido en
nuestra historia
un indígena zapoteco
benito juárez garcía
se le
conoció como el benemérito de las
américas
hoy están
importante
sí
proceder y su fama
[Música]
benito mussolini
lleva a ese nombre porque es su papá
piso
que se llamará como benito juárez
qué hizo
nuestro proceso
con la reforma
que se consumó en ese tiempo separó al
estado de la iglesia antes
en otros países
practica el principio bíblico de que a
dios lo que es de dios y al césar lo que
es del césar
luego
se llevó a cabo una tercera
transformación
a finales del siglo 19 y principios del
siglo 20 la revolución mexicana de 1910
se luchó
por la democracia porque se padecía de
una dictadura que se impuso durante 34
años
se luchó
para qué
se garantizarán las libertades y se
luchó también por la justicia dirigentes
sociales muy importantes
los hermanos flores magón que fueron
precursores de esa revolución
desde luego un hombre bueno apóstol de
la democracia que fue asesinado
cobardemente
francisco y madero
y dirigentes sociales
como francisco villas
dirigente defensor de los campesinos
lineal al pueblo emiliano zapata
con esta tercera transformación
se avanzó mucho
en el terreno de lo social
no lo suficiente en el terreno político
porque
no se pudo establecer una auténtica una
verdadera
democracia en el país después de la
revolución se creó un partido único que
dominó durante mucho tiempo y apenas
ahora
estamos
dando los primeros pasos para que méxico
sea un país verdadera auténticamente
democrático
posiblemente por la falta de democracia
entre otros factores
se fue
echando a perder la vida pública mi país
empezó a esperar la corrupción política
que fue durante mucho tiempo el
principal problema de méxico nuestro
país con muchas riquezas naturales que
tiene buenas tierras para la producción
agropecuaria agua en abundancia petróleo
minas y un pueblo bueno noble trabajador
posee dos repito de una
herencia cultural milenaria
d
donde emana la vocación del pueblo por
el trabajo
por la creatividad
bueno con todo y eso no podíamos avanzar
x
la corrupción
que imperaba
nosotros desde hace mucho tiempo venimos
luchando para conseguir un verdadero
cambio en el país y así lo decidió
después de muchos años el pueblo de
mexico nos eligió y nos hemos propuesto
llevar a cabo la cuarta transformación
de la vida pública de nuestro país y
hable de la independencia de la reforma
de la revolución y ahora estamos
empeñados comprometidos en llevar a cabo
la cuarta transformación de la vida
pública del país sin violencia
de manera pacífica y lo estamos logrando
a pesar
de que estamos enfrentando dos crisis
como también
se está
padeciendo en otros países del mundo
estamos enfrentando la pandemia
de el coronavirus del cob y 19
esta enfermedad
terrible
y estamos enfrentando también lo que
desató o produjo originó esta pandemia
la crisis económica como en otros países
estamos enfrentando al mismo tiempo dos
crisis pero vamos aliento
estamos
y avanzando
enfrentando la pandemia
hemos actuado con responsabilidad nos
han ayudado mucho los expertos los
científicos los médicos las enfermeras
los trabajadores de la salud
que se han entregado como humanismo para
salvar vidas
y vamos avanzando
bajando disminuyendo
el efecto nocivo de la pandemia lo que
más nos importa es salvar vidas
se va avanzando y también en lo
económico
por qué
no aplicamos
la misma estrategia de siempre
endeudar al país
de rescatar a los de arriba
con el sofisma de que si llueve fuerte
arriba gotea abajo
como si la riqueza fuese contagiosa
que hicimos
pues estamos apoyando abajo y de manera
directa al pueblo
es de abajo hacia arriba
estamos destinando recursos que son
fruto del ahorro por no permitir la
corrupción
y fruto también de la austeridad
republicana
porque ya no hay lujos en el gobierno
les comento que
había un avión presidencial y existe
todavía pero está en venta ya lo rifamos
y todavía vamos a venderlo
este avión
e
es como un palacio
en los cielos
algo
insultante para nuestro pueblo
un avión
de lujo
para 240 pasajeros adaptados para
y 80
con sala de junta con recámara
algo repito
ofensivos entonces ya el presidente de
méxico quien les habla se traslada
por carreteras
en vehículos
y el avión de línea
está permitido utilizar aviones
helicópteros
particulares para funcionarios para
servidores públicos
también entre otras cosas
desapareció un cuerpo de élite que
cuidaba al presidente saben cuantos
cuidaban al presidente ocho mil
elementos se llamaba esa institución que
venía de tiempo atrás estado mayor
presidencial
y así
se han terminado lujos las
extravagancias no puede haber gobierno
rico con pueblo pobre entonces la
fórmula es no permitir la corrupción y
ahorrar
que no haya ostentación lujos en el
gobierno
y también liberar fondos para el
desarrollo entonces todo lo que estamos
reuniendo
con esta fórmula de no permitir la
corrupción y de hacer un gobierno
austero sobrio estamos destinando a
apoyar a la gente humilde
a los desposeídos
todos los adultos mayores de méxico
tienen
derecho a una pensión
todas las niñas los niños con
discapacidad también reciben una pensión
11 millones de estudiantes pobres
reciben becas y así muchos programas
sociales entonces esto que se está
invirtiendo abajo
acompañado del apoyo que nos están
brindando nuestros paisanos migrantes
los que por necesidad se fueron a
buscarse a la vida a trabajar en eeuu
que ya son 38 millones de mexicanos los
que
[Música]
nacieron aquí también los que han nacido
allá de padres mexicanos 38 millones
pues nos están ayudando mandan a sus
familiares en méxico
apoyos económicos
las llamadas remesas
este año a pesar de
la pandemia
va a ser un año récord entre meses
se van a recibir alrededor de 40 mil
millones de dólares
y ese dinero mes con mes llega a 10
millones de familias todas
de nuestro país entonces con lo que
estábamos invirtiendo
desde el gobierno y con las remesas
estamos fortaleciendo el consumo y a
pesar de la pandemia y de la crisis no
hay hambre
en nuestro país se está garantizando el
consumo básico
a millones de mexicanos y ya poco a poco
se va recuperando la economía esto
también se complementa con el hecho de
que acabamos de firmar un acuerdo con
eeuu y canadá un tratado que ya entró en
vigor
y esto significa que están llegando
inversiones al país
se están instalando empresas y se están
creando empleos para el bienestar
y los mexicanos
tengo mucha fe en el futuro de méxico
pero también
tengo mucha fe en el futuro del mundo
yo soy un creyente
y mi credo es el de la fraternidad
universal por eso yo les envío a todas a
todos un abrazo
desde la ciudad de méxico capital de
nuestra república